hi welcome to ask IJ and Jenna's here -
so she's can I assist with the answering
of the questions that's what I do we
also did the same video on her channel
but we switched sides so it looked a
little bit different
yeah we were too lazy to change our
clothes it's not gonna happen No yeah
all right let's get you these questions
here we go this one's from Kevin he says
do you have any new year's resolutions
oh um well I would like to UM find a job
hahaha but I would like to not be a lazy
bum ha ha ha I would like that too
actually
okay next question when will you have a
meet-up in Pittsburgh not this trip you
forgot really busy how many video games
106 hours worth what games are looking
forward to next year I am looking
forward to dead space 3 and the last of
us and one others Dead Island oh yeah I
thought was a deal see with the new Dead
Island but what does it call my friend
it's hidden called know it's like rip
tired or something Riptide I don't know
what that's not of all it is called rip
Todd pilan
the Riptide sequel should be pretty fun
I didn't finish the first one truthfully
I like the missions so much better than
far cry 3 than it did Island I feel like
that I'm so bored I was like you want me
to find our stick I have so many sticks
I don't know what to do with them I play
it
Lina wants to know how was our day today
good rivers great breakfast we need to
pop evidence ovens it was Toys R Us
again we got we got toys for what
cousins
that's for you this is for me sounds
reason I swear we got toys a toys look
how I just love caravan isn't it nuts
nobody's a DVD DVD about yours what else
we good mario backpack i like that i
know i hope he doesn't like it so i can
have
he got a little spider-man now so you're
a hit me no this is for little people
heads should I do the rest of this video
in that battle Ranger mask what's up
guys it's me I mixed meat jelly you can
find me on youtube.com slash it's me
Jenny or and twitter.com slash Jenny's
are on Facebook okay let's also impose
Jenny's and shut up Terrence fan says
what's your favorite TV series as of
today my favorite TV series me this one
I'm talking right now I might have to be
ruin bit you can see me no stop living
certificates you talk it or me talking
Mon favorite TV series is French I
absolutely love French it's like my
favorite show I absolutely love Dexter
I'm crying you can't it's in the back
I'm gonna pet llama what would you name
it I would be with Jason mom I would
name it Molly
we take these off now let's pause in
there 7-piece oh look it's a root beer
flavor get out of here
I am NOT going anywhere what is our
favorite Starbucks drink I like the
whites Milkha's I actually had not had a
welcome I had not had milk in like two
years and then I just somebody had a
craving for peppermint mocha because
while would these festive drinks
throughout November of a mocha Jenna was
so good it's for live events if I am to
my pants but almost did here's what it
says how did you meet Ryan hey Wes yeah
you want to come here and answer a
question why pause your game Blizzard
puns far cry they may want to know how
we met look at this I'm showing them all
the toys we got cause come on didn't
just get them in here well there's two I
would give her a lot of grief and banter
via Twitter but how we actually met
before that happened was on Friday Night
Fights season one she was a contestant
against Michelle Rodriguez my team won
your team did boy because I was coaching
and I was actually supposed to coach
Michelle Rodriguez but I wanted to coach
Justine instead is this a show and I
switched my me up no she was like next
time you'll see my movies you're going
to be
in Anna's face I was like actually did a
really good Michelle Rodriguez
impression thank you okay that's
progress we thanks right John see I'm
partying yeah yeah you can ask ah ha ha
ha
today's my birthday what should I buy my
Christmas BD cash cash cash money money
you can't buy money with money sure what
should I buy who's a girl boy girl boy
Chandler Chandler Chandler I think you
should go by date all of the friend
series cuz I love friends it's yours
Chandler me too you know what client
wants to know if we have ever eaten a
meal using only a spatula I actually
have not mommy make cookies is a day and
I match lemon icing - Chandler will
question were asking your spatula we
already got Chandler's questions um okay
well sir what's your favorite cocktail
I like water a lot I don't like to drink
what's my favorite filter on Instagram
Ciara because it makes your complexion
look fantastic
low-five low-five good - it just because
my clown pictures it really brings out
the David what are you making your way
to CD so we can do a photo shoot I have
known David for well I've actually never
really met him in person but we've known
each other on the internet for many many
years
so I don't really have any plans on
coming to a CT anytime soon so I'll have
to make some wins so I didn't answer
your question but I'll work on that one
he can be any character of a game who
would you be I know who I wouldn't be I
would not be told because he is such a
little baby always
my special prize is hanging out fear bad
but knowing yourself I would be Yoshi I
like Yoshi but you know what Yoshi
always highlight Yoshi I've been
princess because she does absolutely
nothing and I think it's great she just
gets stolen from Castle to Castle to
Castle and it's just probably eating the
finest like pushing me up hahaha I'm
like this princess is probably eating
the finest needles in Bowser's Castle
he's probably treating her wisely hiding
her she knows probably she wants to get
stolen
she doesn't 1r yeah her for like how
long like 20 18 20 years now probably
even more shouldn't they just lock her
up and Carol I go outside I would be
like girl like I'm done with you she
sneaks out she wants those fine meals
from Bowser she wants those meals okay
what's your favorite movie
I've no idea I don't really like movies
yeah Brian what is the best quality that
you see in each other
Jenna you have nice hair Thank You
Justine you have beautiful beautiful
eyes
yeah I can't do there thank you I don't
know no comment either my braces for
like 10 years I just that really goofy
is asking how much longer do I plan on
making YouTube videos we were actually
just discussing for this today I'm
probably gonna make them forever it's a
lot of work it's very good you're like
oh you just make videos and post we tell
you what it's not just well you make a
video but it's a lot of work if it is I
mean really real videos you edit edit
choose to upload import ideas promote
edit ever made oh it's fun though I do
thoroughly enjoy it
why does Bri hate being on YouTube so
much why did you guys color orange yeah
she is on he just wears a little bronzer
she was a little too much bronzer be
nice brave it you could be mean to me
cuz I don't care
hey this looks like a muppet hahahaha
your mom is so blah I know I can do it's
like look at that like that's all you're
normal
okay guys give me a heading lay a rubber
bag golly Papa haha Caitlyn the decimals
our favorite video game I'm called to do
chamber cam did you cried Colin how many
copies King yes but we have playing far
cry from holidays let me tell you what
it was an absolutely fantastic game I
hear game of the year you should have a
game of the year too bad it came out too
late um come to tea coffee and ecology
and coffee okay guys ready go cover up
that this video and Jenna is drinking so
much coffee I think my face is hurting
I'm doing that so much make sure you
subscribe so that you can see more of
this face hahaha hope you guys have a
happy new year oh yeah heal you yours
come the new year five guys do Union
presents I'm freaked out